ليس من المستغرب أننا رأينا أشخاصًا
يبحثون عن أصول بديلة أخرى
مثل الأصول الرقمية وعملة
البيتكوين وأنا أعلم أنني متأكد من أنك تُسأل
عن هذا الأمر طوال الوقت ،
لكنني أرغب في الحصول على حكمتك حول هذا الأمر
لأنني رأيت  تدلي ببعض التعليقات
حول
هيكل السوق فقط وعلى
المستويات التي تشارك فيها أنواع مختلفة من
المستثمرين وربما ما
يحتاج الأشخاص الجدد في شيء مثل
البيتكوين إلى مراقبته
للتحدث كنوع من المستثمرين التقليديين
ولكنهم يفهمون حركة
السعر.
وعقلية المستثمرين عندما
يقومون بالاستثمار ، خاصةً مثل
تحركات الأسعار التي رأيناها
محمد حكمتك على البيتكوين ،
لذلك لا أعرف أنها حكمة لأنني
اشتريت عملات البيتكوين عندما انخفضوا إلى ما دون 5000
وباع أنا وأنا  سنهم 19000 ، واعتقدت
أنني ذكي حقًا ، فهذا
ربح يصل إلى 40000.
لذلك أنا لست متأكدًا من أنها حكمة ولكن
هذه هي الطريقة التي يجب أن يفكر بها الناس
هذه المرة لأن هذا هو
الارتفاع الكبير الثالث
في أسعار البيتكوين هذه المرة
لدينا أساس متين
من حاملي العملات على المدى الطويل الذين
تجمعهم الخوف من التضخم ، والخوف
من عدم ثقة السيولة في المؤسسات التي تتطلع
إلى المزيد من أصول تخفيف المخاطر ، أعني
مجموعة كاملة من الأسباب التي تجعلهم  معًا ،
هذا أساس متين لهذا السبب
لا أعتقد أنك سترى
عملات البيتكوين على الإطلاق تتراجع إلى 4000. ولكن
أعلاه هناك طبقة كبيرة من
التكهنات
يدرك الناس أن عملات البيتكوين يمكن أن تتحرك بنسبة
أربعة أو خمسة
بالمائة في اليوم وهذا  بالطبع
يجذب الأشخاص الذين رأيناهم
الأسبوع الماضي مذهلًا أنه عندما تصل
عمليات التحقق من التحفيز
إلى حساب الناس ،
انتهى الأمر بشراء عملات البيتكوين بعدد قليل جدًا من هذه الدولارات ،
لذلك يتكهن الناس على عملة البيتكوين ،
لذلك أخبر الناس فقط توخي الحذر
لأنني أستطيع أن أفهم الأساس المتين
ولكن على  علاوة على ذلك ،
لديك طبقة كبيرة للمضاربين ، لذا
تأكد فقط من قدرتك على الإدارة من
خلال ذلك لأنه كما رأينا يوم الأحد ،
يمكن أن ينخفض السعر بمقدار  20 في المائة في 48
ساعة ،
نعم ، يجب أن تكون مستعدًا
للتقلبات ، أعني أنه سيكون هناك أشخاص
يشاهدون هذا الأمر
كل الأسباب التي اقترحتها أو
سبب شراء البيتكوين
لا يزال موجودًا وسيستمر في الوجود
في عام 2021. لذلك أنا  هل تعتقد أن عملات البيتكوين
ستستمر في تأسيس
نفسها ،
لكن من المهم أن تعرف ما الذي
يؤسسون أنفسهم
لأنهم يؤسسون أنفسهم كجزء
من نظام الدفع
الذي يؤسسون أنفسهم
كممتلكات
في محفظة واحد بالمائة 2 بالمائة
ما هم  لا تقوم البنوك المركزية بتأسيس نفسها على
أنها عملة عالمية لن تسمح البنوك المركزية
بحدوث ذلك وأعتقد أنه مهم لأن ذلك
يمنحك تقييماً حدودياً
بوضوح ليس صفرًا لأنهم موجودون
في النظام البيئي
ولكنني لا أسمع بعض الناس يقولون
إنه سيحدث  إلى 400000
لا أعتقد ذلك ، لذا فأنت تعلم فقط أنك
تفهم أنه نطاق ضخم
ولكنك تدرك أنه مقيد ببعض
الحقائق